ترى أن المدافعين عن حدود إيران
سيحصلون على ردود قوية وحازمة ضد
أي غزو هناك.
لحماية النظام من
الداخل إلى الخارج ضد تهديدات مثل الهراء المستوحاة من الغرب التي
رأوها من قبل ، لكن
الحرب مع العراق غيرت كل شيء خلال
8 سنوات شاقة في
معركة عابرة ملطخة بالدماء ، مما حول
الحرس الثوري الإيراني إلى قوة خارجية أكثر تقليدية.
لا يوجد أي
طموح إقليمي ولا حتى داخل
تطبيقك ، وهذا ليس صحيحًا تمامًا ،
فالحراس الآن يدوسون في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
بأهداف بسيطة.
إيران منذ عام
1982 الحرب مع العراق تموج
بطرق أخرى بعد مساعدة الحرس الثوري الإيراني
إعادة بناء الدولة ومن هناك
تشابك نفسها عبر كل جزء
من الاقتصاد
.
نظام رعب كبير يصفه الأمريكيون
بأنهم إرهابيون يلومونهم
لسنوات من التفجيرات ، تعترف إيران
بالولايات المتحدة كأول عدو لها ،
لذا يمكنهم من مقاتلي الحرية الذين يمثلون
في نواح كثيرة قانونًا لأنفسهم